so now that we have multiple solutions i
guess it's time to come up to a decision
and to come up with one solution right
that's right
so the decide stage is important in
helping filter down the ideas that were
collected
the previous stage which is about
diverging
has
made it so that everyone has created a
lot of sketches and they're starting to
develop some passion and attachment to
the things that they have
during the decide stage we ask the team
to put their ideas on the board so
everyone can see them
at that point we ask people to remain
silent we call this process zen voting
just like in a zen spirit you want to be
quiet and consider things in a
reflective manner during this process we
ask people to review what the sketches
are before anyone gets to bias them with
their opinions
so as they review the sketches that
other people have created they start
thinking what do they like about the
other solutions and you you're always
curious i made this what did the other
what what did the others make it's fun
to see that
after everybody has voted it is time to
actually discuss things in person
so
something that's not natural to teams
happen that's really valuable people had
individual personal time to be creative
then they had personal time to view
results and they had time to consider
and cast their vote before anyone else
could say i think this is important and
so they got biased
so
now that they have gone through that
they're ready to look at things as a
community
as a community the team reviews what are
the ideas or the most popular ones and
then quickly they get to see well
clearly some things rise to the top and
maybe others are less important so their
minds has changed based on what the
community has decided
research shows that this community based
voting can be more powerful than the
decisions of a single expert for example
if you have a horse race and experts
betting on the horses and if you have a
crowdsourcing solution in which you're
testing who is making a whole crowd is
making predictions on who will win it is
likely that the crowd might often beat
the experts
over what you
usually think is that the expert will be
more powerful crowdsourcing a decision
makes the team decide faster and it
helps the team often gather the wisdom
of everyone who is involved so what
could go wrong in this stage what could
go wrong in this stage
decisions are crucial aspect of what
teams do in fact the life of a team is
made of all of the decisions that they
make so we could not pretend that this
is an easy um that is an easy process
for teams
things can go wrong if one person is
trying to overpower and put the opinions
over others
this this happens all the time
this is why we have a leader of a sprint
the leader of the sprint is watching the
entire group they want to make sure that
the introverts and the extroverts are
heard the designers and the engineers
the ceo and the intern everyone could
have a great decision at this point
so at this stage we look at the
solutions we vote and we make a call
that's right